a very warm welcome to all our viewers
this is Angela from simply learned and
today I'll be showing you the
installation procedure for the
configuration management tool puppet so
what exactly is the use of puppet if you
consider the scenario of an organization
which has a very large infrastructure
it's required that all the systems and
servers in this infrastructure is
continously maintained at a desired
State this is where puppet comes in
puppet automates this entire procedure
thus reducing the manual work so before
we move on to the demo let me tell you
what the architecture of puppet looks
like so puppet has two main components
you have the puppet master and the
puppet client the puppet master is very
right configuration files and store them
and the puppet client are basically
those client machines which require the
configuration in case of puppet these
configuration files that you write are
called manifests so let's move on to the
demo so here are my two machines the
first is the server system which is
basically a master where you'll write
your configuration files and the others
the node or the client system so let's
have a look at both of these machines
this my node system the terminal is open
here and the terminal has a black
background with white text and as of my
server or the master machine it has a
black background with green text so we
started a server machine the first thing
that we need to do is we need to remove
the firewall so in a lot of cases there
are chances that the firewall stops the
connection between your server and your
note now since I'm doing a demo and I'm
just showing you how a puppet works
between two virtual boxes I can safely
remove the firewall without any worries
but when you're implementing puppet in
an organization or a number of systems
on a local network be careful about the
consequences of doing so
so firewall is disabled next thing that
we do is we'll change the hostname of
our server system now while using the
puppet tool it's always advisable that
you name your servers host as puppet
this because the puppet tool identifies
the hostname puppet by default as the
host name for the master or the server
system
let's just check if the horse team has
changed successfully yep so that's done
so as you see still localhost is
appearing as the host theme so just
close your terminal and start it again
and you see here the host team has been
changed to puppet okay so the next thing
that we have to do is we install our
puppet labs make sure your system is
connected to the net
right to puppet labs is installed next
we need to install the puppet server
service on our server system
you
now that a puppet server services
installed we need to move into the
system configurations for a puppet
server so the path for that is EDC sis
config puppet server
so this is a configuration file for the
puppet server now if you come down to
this line now this line here this is the
line which allocates memory for your
puppet server now you must remember that
puppet is a very resource extensive tool
so just in case to ensure that we do not
encounter any errors because of out of
memory we will reduce these sizes so as
of now we have 2 GB allocated by default
we'll change this to 512 MB now in a lot
of cases it may work without doing so
but just to be on the safer side we make
this change
save it and go back to your turban we
are now ready to start our puppet
service service
the first time you start your puppet
self-service it may take a while
next we need to enable this
and if your puppet service services
started and enabled successfully this is
the output that you would get in case
you're still not sure you can always
check the status at any point of time
and as you see here it's active so
everything's fine as of now next thing
we do is we'll move on to our agent
system or at line or node system so here
- we'll have to install puppet labs but
before we do so we need to make a small
change in our host file so let's open
the host file
yeah so the Salvos file we need to add a
single line here which specifies our
puppet master
so first we put our puppet masters IP
address followed by the hostname and
then we'll add a dns for a puppet server
so let's just go back to a server system
and find out its IP address
and that's my IP address for the server
system
now the host name of our puppet server
and a DNS for it save this file and
return to your terminal so now we can
download our puppet labs on the node
system is the exact same procedure that
you followed for downloading puppet labs
on your server system to
so in my note system the puppet labs is
already downloaded so the next thing is
we need to install a puppet agent
service
so puppet is a pull type of
configuration tool what this means is
that all your configuration files that
you'd be writing on your server is
pulled by the node system as and when it
requires it so this is the co
functionality of the agent service which
is installed on your client node or
agent system so my puppet agent service
is installed so next I'll just check if
my puppet server is reachable from this
node system so eight one four zero is a
port number that the puppet server must
be listening on and it's connected to
puppet so that guarantees that your
server is reachable from the node system
so now that everything's configured
right we can start our agent service
so guys you would have noticed that the
command for starting the agent service
is a little more complex in the command
for starting your service service this
is because when you start your agent
service you are not just starting a
service but you're also creating a
certificate this is the certificate that
will be sent over to your master system
now at the master system there's
something called the certificate
authority
this gives the master the rights to sign
a certificate if it agrees to share
information with that particular node so
let's execute this command which does
body function of sending the certificate
and starting your agent service so as
you can see here our services started
successfully it's in a running state now
we'll move to our Master System or the
server system
so first we'll have a look at the
certificates that we received the
certificate should be in this location
so as you can see here this is the
certificate that we just received from
our agent service so this here within
quotes is the name of our certificate so
next when we are signing the certificate
this is the name we'll provide to
specify that this is the particular
certificate that we want to sign so the
minute we sign a certificate the note
that send the certificate gets a
notification that the master has
accepted your request so after this we
can begin sharing our manifest files now
here's the command for signing this
certificate
okay so our certificate is signed which
means that the north's request is
approved and the minute the certificate
is signed the request is removed from
this list so now if we execute the same
command as we did to check the list of
all the certificates we will not find
the certificate anymore let's just check
that so as you see now there are no more
requests pending because we have
accepted all the requests if you want to
have a look at all the certificates that
is signed or unsigned you can use the
same command with the addition of all
and all the certificates received so far
will be listed as you can see here the
plus sign indicates that this
certificate requests has already been
accepted so now that our certificate is
signed the next thing we do is we create
a sample manifest file
so this is the part that you create your
manifest files in our filename is
sampled or PP and a file is created so
right now we have no content in this
file we just check if the agent is
receiving it and once that's confirmed
we'll add some content to the file so
let's move to an agent system
now this the command to execute at the
agent system to pull your configuration
files
so a cat flock is applied in 0.02
seconds so now that the communication
between our agent system and our master
system is working perfectly fine let's
add some content to the previous
placeholder file that we created on our
master system so now we open the same
file in an editor
okay so we are going to write a code for
installing the httpd package on our node
system which is basically a Apache
service node and then within quotes
insert the hostname of your node system
so my node system source name is climbed
the package you wish to install which in
our case is HTTP D and the action to be
performed and that's it a very small and
simple code save this file
now let's go back to our node system and
let's pull the second version of the
same configuration file so every time
you execute this command as we did
previously - what happens is in the
agent service so the agent service
basically checks on your master system
if there's any new configuration file
added or if there's any change to the
previous configuration file made if so
then the catalog is applied once again
so now our catalogs applied in 1.5 5
seconds so now to check if a catalog
served its purpose let's just open a
browser just type localhost here and as
you can see if your HTTP D package has
been successfully installed the Apache a
testing page will appear here so we come
to an end offer installation and
configuration of the configuration
management tool puppet if you have any
doubts regarding this please post them
in the comment section below and we'll
definitely get back to you also hit the
like button if you liked this video and
subscribe to our channel as we have more
coming up this is angela from simply
learned signing off see y'all next time
hi there if you liked this video
subscribe to the simple learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos Dinard up and get certified click
here